on
va faire une interview mensonge alors
j'allais commencer l'interview mensonge
vous répondez linverse de la vérité vous
montez khaled interview mon sens
[Musique]
alors khaled comment ça va pas bien
vous êtes content d'être ici ce soir non
ça vous fait quel âge maintenant 11 ans
ça fait cinq ans c'est vrai parce que
vous êtes
février et g10 avait 11 ans parce que je
le dis parce que cette année cgt et en
2012 avait eu 10 ans
est ce que c'est vrai rat m e vous
porter la moustache en hommage à francis
cabrel
[Rires]
ou à saddam hussein oui
c'est vrai que j'avais vu teindre en
blonde oui vous avez grossi la non
un petit peu
c'est vrai que vous êtes mis à manger du
porc maintenant oui grave c'est surtout
le marcassin
et et du bacon dans le club sandwich 1
la peinture
allen vous allez arrêter de boire non
définitivement
ça fait huit ans maintenant 8 ans vous
avez arrêté votre dernière quick c'était
ave 2 3 soleil mais dakar voilà c'est
que c'est l'interview mensonge là
maintenant je vois toujours
je suis
d'accord pas de bol je pense qu'il ya
pas mal à se faire plaisir si le plus
dur alors là
il est comment votre nouveau disque là
il est pas dire du tout vous en êtes
fier du tout vous pensez être le
meilleur chanteur de raï du monde
aujourd'hui
non
l'objectf fans de jenifer de la star ac
voulait mais beaucoup vous avez tous ses
disques the ladder grave
cheb mami vous l'aimez bien mon dieu que
je les adore
et faudel vous le trouvez comment
va pas bien pas bien du tout pas bien du
tout marc olivier fogiel vous l'aimez
bien à lui je dois crise grave le
sénat ben alouane la télévision
vous préférez son émission la mienne
sans émission vous êtes heureux
aujourd'hui radel
non c'est vrai que vous êtes un grand b
heures
oui
vous aimez votre femme khaled non vous
l'avait déjà trompée
plusieurs fois plusieurs fois vous êtes
quand on est venu ce soir là non et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu